after Super Tuesday Donald Trump is well
on his way to scoring the magic number
of Delegates whoever gets there first
wins the Republican nomination so why
are all these other guys still in the
race well they hope to stop Trump from
reaching that magic number if they do
that the fight goes to the convention in
July so how exactly can they stop him
well there's a couple ways the first way
two candidates would need to
respectfully bow out leaving Trump
against a the establishment friendly
Rubio this way it's thought Rubio could
get the delegates that would have gone
to the other guys this just might be
enough to catch up to trump but what
actually seems to be happening is
they're all staying in the race that's
because they can still all make some
gains in states where delegates are
awarded proportionally based on the boat
but here's the thing some primaries
coming up our winner-take-all like these
ones which could be good for Trump
because if he wins by even a little bit
he takes all the delegates but Marco
Rubio hopes to suite winner-take-all
Florida which has 99 delegates it's his
home state after all and John Kasich is
hoping for the same in Ohio where he's
governor that's 66 delegates that could
go to him and not Trump but that's under
estimating Trump's appeal all across the
country oh and the other thing these
rules about which primaries are winner
take all or proportional they're all
arbitrary set by the RNC and the states
and their different every election so in
order to stop Trump a lot of random
pieces have to fall exactly into place
sweet first I like to eat the little
baby hands and then I like to eat a
little baby feet and then I like to make
it suffer
and that's when it got to flip